- I am so incredibly
honored to be here tonight
to celebrate the great Carol Littleton.
(audience clapping and cheering)
Where are you, there you are.
I think it's safe to say
that all of us are here,
because we have an abiding
passion to create stories
that will resonate in
the human heart and soul
and will help us understand who we are,
where we came from, where we're going,
and why we are feeling what we feel.
And I think all of us would agree
that films are ultimately
created in the editing room.
After the pressure, passion,
and drama of shooting a movie,
after the actors and the production crews
have all dispersed,
hopefully to other jobs,
it is in the editing
room that the director
and editor take all
the chosen raw material
and attempt to fashion it
into something extraordinary.
I'm convinced that one of
the most important elements
in all good movies and
an absolute imperative
in all great movies is
the emotional connection
that's established with the
audience in the first act
and is maintained and enhanced
up to the final moment.
The delicacy of that connection
is the mark of a great editor.
Great editing makes us
care, thus rearranging us
in a particular moment or
sometimes for a lifetime.
A great editor is an advocate,
a detective, a humanist, a philosopher,
and in some cases a sensitive
and articulate teacher.
They see things that a
director could have forgotten
or doesn't even know he or she even has,
a turn of a head, the blink of an eye,
the emotional beat that's been truncated
or an elusive moment without which
the connection to the audience
would be irrevocably lost.
It is that delicate.
We are a complex and conflicted species,
and so are our stories,
something fully understood
by skillful editors.
Carol Littleton is a great humanist.
She loves us with all
our faults and foibles.
She does not judge us. She's
after the truth of a moment.
She knows that in our ignorance,
despite ourselves, if led gently,
or not so gently by the hand,
we have the collective
capacity to sense what is true,
and it is that truth that
moves us, that changes us.
"The Big Chill" was my second film.
Thank you, Larry, for trusting
that the strange and
eccentric nurse, Jenny Fields,
in "The World According to Garp,"
(audience clapping and cheers)
could also be this nurturing
steady, I thought for a while,
boring Sarah Cooper, in "The Big Chill."
We became a family with
two sets of parents,
Larry and Meg Kasdan and John
Bailey and Carol Littleton.
(audience clapping)
And though time and
distance has separated us
through the years, we remain a family.
Indeed, we have endured our first losses,
the great loved,
humanly-conflicted, Bill Hurt,
and our father, mentor,
friend, and industry leader,
John Bailey, Carol's beloved husband.
(audience clapping)
For me, "The Big Chill"
was the true beginning
of my education in the
craft of film acting.
I was so incredibly lucky to
be in such brilliant hands,
because in retrospect, it
was really the wordless,
beautifully edited moments
that gave Sarah Cooper
her emotional weight with the audience,
crying in the shower,
joining the group after
smiling at Mary Kay after
she'd had sex with my husband,
if you haven't seen the movie, see it,
and dancing in the kitchen.
I really thank you, Carol, for
putting my butt in that shot,
because it made me look
like a really good dancer,
even though I was by far the worst.
It was while filming "The Big Chill"
that I learned the power
of thought in film.
But you know, you can act
until your panties fray
and the cows come home, and
it won't resonate for a second
unless you were led by a John Bailey,
directed by a Larry Kasdan
and edited with love,
intelligence, empathy, and rigor
by none other than the
truly great human being,
Carol Littleton.
(bright music)